[Applaus]
[Musik]
vor kurzem haben wir euch in einem
unserer videos es hat dort vorgestellt
ein land das sich als die avantgarde der
krypto währungen sieht die kleine nation
wirbt für sich aber auch mit ihren
wunderschönen stränden und perfekten
wellen ein paradies für surfer lasst
euch heute von uns also noch mal in
dieses trübe schlachteten führen und
essen näher kennenlernen
[Musik]
seit aber gewarnt wir werden heute
weniger über mit kulows offen sprechen
sondern über den gewalttätigsten staat
der welt ja ihr habt euch nicht verhört
wir reden immer noch über das gleiche
land el salvador der die realität der
menschen dort wird weniger durch
wellenreiten und magische internet
müssen bestimmt sondern durch die
berüchtigten des salvadorianischen games
migranten tracks und die höchste
mordrate der welt und das ist nur die
spitze des eisbergs
um die eine vorstellung zu geben el
salvadors mordraten ist vergleichbar mit
der von ländern die sich im krieg
befänden im jahr 2015 bleibt die
mordrate in diesem land bei einem
ermordeten pro 1000 einwohnern um das in
die richtige perspektive zu rücken in el
salvador werden mehr menschen ermordet
als bei verkehrsunfällen ums leben
kommen wir sprechen hier über das land
der maras das sind ultra brutale straßen
banken sie widmen sich meist den drogen
handeln
ihre mitglieder unterscheiden sich
voneinander durch tattoos die
typischerweise ihre ganzen körper
bedecken die zwei wichtigsten banken
sind die mara salvatrucha und die mara
barrio 18 um die eine vorstellung vom
ausmaß des problems zu geben schätzt man
das barrio 18 zwischen 50.000 und
100.000 mitglieder hat aber wir reden
nicht nur über gewalt ein drittel des
salvadorianischen von weniger als 550
pro tag die überweisungen von auslands
salvadorianer machen fast 20 prozent des
gesamten bruttoinlandsprodukts des
landes aus mit anderen worten wir
sprechen von einem der trostlosen und
hoffnungslosesten länder der welt aber
was wäre wenn ich dir jetzt sagen würde
dass sich das alles ändert ja in der tat
von zeit zu zeit tauchen charaktere auf
die in der lage sind den lauf der
geschichte zu verändern und dieses video
wird sich mit einem solchen
protagonisten begriff machen dem neuen
polit rockstar lateinamerikas
[Musik]
die rede ist von nike dem präsidenten el
salvadors die meisten leute außerhalb
mittel und südamerikas dem namen noch
nie gehört haben aber glaubt mir in
lateinamerika ist er der neue messias
und die wahrheit ist dass es sich
tatsächlich um eine einzigartige
persönlichkeit handelt innerhalb der nur
zwei jahre seiner präsidentschaft hat es
geschafft die kriminalität um die hälfte
zu reduzieren
nicht einmal das corona virus hat es
geschafft seine popularität zu
beeinträchtigen er ist ein revolutionär
aber nicht der klassische linke
revolutionär pokale ist einer der
jüngsten politischen führer in
lateinamerika er ist 39 jahre alt um
ständig in den sozialen medien präsent
und er hat keine angst erfolg drastische
entscheidungen zu treffen wie wir
bereits berichtet haben hat er vor
kurzem dem bitcoin als legales
zahlungsmittel in el salvador 1 geführt
doch trotz all seiner errungenschaften
verfügte ausgerechnet in washington dc
nicht über besonders viel vertrauen
us-senatoren bitten beiden druck auf
präsident böge auszuüben was aus amerika
was ist also dran an lokale ich bin mir
sicher dass viele von euch es sich schon
denken können ist wäre ja nicht das
erste mal dass lateinamerika auf einen
neuen messias hereinfällt der wunder
verspricht und sich am ende als tyrann
entpuppt und die wahrheit ist nun mal
das ist sehr viele anzeichen dafür gibt
dass lokale el salvador in eine diktatur
verwandeln könnte die fragen die wir uns
heute stellen lauten also was treibt die
kehle inessa da reden wir über den
helden denen dieses land wirklich
braucht oder ist er nur ein weiterer
aufstrebender tür an der einfach zuviel
tropico gespielt habt heute werden wir
all diese fragen beantworten aber zuerst
müssen wir einen kurzen blick in die
geschichte werfen
[Musik]
bohren die erste frage du dich
vielleicht test ist woher kommt der name
niki ich meine klingt doch eher wie ein
arabischer name rolle nun da hast du
recht ein teil von michaels familie
kommt aus palästina dies mag wie eine
randnotiz erscheinen aber es ist ein
weiteres symbol dafür wie weit dieser
mann und der konventionellen politik
entfernt ist du wirst in selten in anzug
und krawatte sehen aber die unterschiede
gehen weit über image und herkunft
hinaus
[Musik]
um diese politische figur vollständig zu
verstehen müssen sie ein wenig über die
geschichte el salvadors wissen im jahr
1979 führte die salvadorianische armee
einen staatsstreich durch und errichtete
einen militär runter im land es brach
ein bürgerkrieg aus zwischen der linken
guerilla der sogenannten nationalen
befreiungsfront farabundo marti kurz-
und im militär dieser krieg endete erst
1992 und forderte mehr als 75.000
todesopfer im jahr 1992 gingen die
beiden seiten jedoch von der
konfrontation auf der straße zur
konfrontation an der wahlurne über
zumindest offiziell denn in wirklichkeit
hat sich nicht viel geändert brutale
gewalt auf die straßen und erstickende
korruption in den amtsstuben gehören in
ascot zum alltag im jahr 2015 tracht das
kleine land seinen eigenen rekord bei
der mordrate und keine der beiden großen
parteien entschied gewillt daran etwas
zu ändern doch am dritten oktober 2008
zehnter hätten sich die dinge für immer
aus respekt vor dem gesetz statt der
heute unseren wahlkampf vokales
geschichte ist eine kuriose geschichte
er begann seine politische karriere in
der sml ndh in einer linken partei so
gewann er das amt des bürgermeisters in
el salvador im jahr 2017 wurde er jedoch
aus der partei gekickt unter normalen
umständen wäre das das ende seiner
karriere gewesen aber dies ist das
einundzwanzigste jahrhundert und
heutzutage haben politiker ein werkzeug
das nur wenige gut zu nutzen wissen
social media
das internet ermöglicht es uns unsere
eigenen kommunikationsmittel zu haben
ohne auf dritte angewiesen zu sein
einige politiker wie donald trump und
alexei navalny haben das gut verstanden
aber zweifelsohne hat neue lokale es
geschafft die digitale kommunikation zu
einer kunstform zu machen dank der
sozialen medien hat lokale den kontakt
zu seinen wählern trotz parteiausschluss
nicht verloren und so kündete er im jahr
2018 seine eigene kampagne und seine
eigene partei an nur was i d as neue
ideen und wächst wahrscheinlich echt
jetzt ist es wirklich so einfach eine
politische partei also über nacht zu
gründen falls ihr vielleicht mal selbst
erfahrung in der politik gesammelt habt
dann wisst ihr bereits dass die gründung
einer politischen partei sehr
kompliziert ist nur einen
charismatischen kandidaten zu haben
reicht nicht aus du musst die basis der
mitglieder organisieren kampagnen planen
und so weiter und so fort wie hat nokia
also seine partei gegründet nun auf
einem wahrlich meisterhafte weise indem
er sich zu einem schied bereits
existierte ja das ist richtig betreiben
einer rechten kleinpartei weit der gaa
ein paar die strategie funktionierte
perfekt lokale bricht el salvadors zwei
parteien macht ja das stimmt pokale hat
mit absoluter mehrheit gewonnen die
vormals kleine splitterpartei die er
quasi übernahmen holten ihm als
spitzenkandidaten plötzlich mehr als 50
prozent der stimmen so hat er die beiden
anderen parteien in die enge getrieben
und das alles im alter von nur 37 jahren
was also war seine erste politische tat
nun sekunden bevor er den amtseid
ablegte bevor er ein einziges wort sagte
dann als sein handy heraus und macht ein
celski um es auf twitter zu posten und
so macht sich es fragen mit welchen
wahlprogramm welche visionen er die
wähler von sich überzeugt hat was hat
nokia den salvatorianer versprochen
damit sie sich auf diese weise in ihn
verlieben nun ganz einfach bei mir immer
besser gleiche passiert mit der
korruption wenn sie in die regierung
kommen stehlen weil sie es schon immer
so gemacht haben sie sehen korruption
als etwas normales an sie sind die
gleichen wie immer und ihre alte art
politik zu machen es gibt genug geld
wenn niemand stehen soll es mag wie ein
einfacher slogan erscheinen aber es war
etwas völlig neues in der politik el
salvadors um die eine vorstellung zu
geben von den letzten vier präsidenten
die dieses land hatte beim 3 und
millionenschwere korruptionsskandale
verwickelt der hashtag der ruhri wanlo
roberto gibt dass die ist gut zurück
klang also wie musik in den ohren der
menschen
[Musik]
aber wir reden hier nicht nur über
innenpolitik den september 2009 zehn
lokale seine erste offizielle rede vor
den vereinten nationen und was denkst du
hat er dort vollbracht nun bevor er ein
richtiges versprach als er bereits am
rednerpult stand machte er ein zelt und
lud ist auf base drum hoch man sich
einfach blendend aus und weist es auch
genau wie seine social media berater um
die eine kleine vorstellung zu geben ok
hat drei millionen follower auf twitter
und zwei millionen auf esta gramm diese
zahlen mögen für einen ranghohen
politiker normal erscheinen aber bedenke
dass die bevölkerung es hat uns nur 64
millionen menschen beträgt das bedeutet
dass ihm fast das halbe volk auf den
asozialen medien folgt wie du siehst
sprechen wir also über einen echten
politischen rockstar aber das wichtigste
an profile ist nicht seine
persönlichkeit sondern seine taten und
hier kommt der überraschung hässliche
teil seiner amtszeit ins spiel
aufgepasst
mit harter hand
wegen korruption und armut ist das
hauptproblem ist dass die gewalt dann
könnte sagen dass die salvadorianischen
marras einen parallel staat im staate
bilden sie leben jenseits des gesetzes
und die polizei traut sich nicht irren
die stirn zu bieten die salvadorianische
städte sind quasi ein kriegsgebiet in
den die banken große territorien unter
ihre kontrolle gebracht haben unter dem
hashtag territorial control plane daher
2500 polizisten und 3000 soldaten in die
hauptstadt des landes entsandt ziel war
es zwölf von den maras kontrollierte
stadtteile zurückzuerobern von einem tag
auf den anderen führte die polizei
kontrollen von waffen drogen und tattoos
durch
[Musik]
denkt mal darüber nach gang mitglieder
sind nun mal leicht zu erkennen weil sie
symbolträchtig und einige tattoos haben
zb sind mitglieder der mara salvatrucha
mit einem m und einem es im gotischen
buchstaben tätowiert na das klingt doch
alles fantastisch nicht wahr wieso gibt
es also eine kontroverse nun diese
ergibt sich aus der art und weise wie
buckel streikmacht vorgeht zum beispiel
hat sich die polizei nicht darauf
beschränkt die täter einfach nur zu
verhaften sondern hat sie auch auf
öffentliche plätze geschleppt um sie
dort vor dem ganzen volk zu demütigen
[Musik]
nicht gerade der rechtsstaatliche ansatz
manche denken aber vielleicht gut andere
länder andere sitten aber funktioniert
dieser ansatz der eisernen faust dann
überhaupt nun im moment sieht es danach
aus im vergleich die mordrate lag 2015
bei 101 macht aufwand pro 100.000
einwohner im jahr 2018 lag sie bei 51
jahr 2009 10 war sie bereits auf 36
gesunden im moment erlebte salvador die
niedrigste gewaltrate seit dem ende des
bürgerkriegs nichtsdestotrotz ist es
halt aber natürlich immer noch ein
extrem gefährliches land und das gleiche
gilt für die korruption
[Musik]
drei monate nach der vereinigung von bug
ag startete deshalb war dort die
internationale kommission gegen
straflosigkeit die sogenannte ccs sie
ist international besetzt um
interessenkonflikte zu vermeiden und in
der tat müssen wir anerkennen dass
michael thelen dank seines politik stieß
in der lage war multi millionen dollar
spenden anzuziehen zb spendete die
wollen buffett foundation 25 millionen
dollar an die salvadorianische polizei
unter normalen umständen wäre fast das
gesamte geld in die taschen irgend eines
politikers geflossen in diesem fall
jedoch finanziert diese 25 millionen
dollar das erste französische
untersuchungszentrum des landes zum
ersten mal in der geschichte el
salvadors wird die polizei in der lage
sein dna tests durchzuführen um
verbrechen aufzuklären aber an dieser
stelle fragst du dich vielleicht wie hat
er denn dass carola virus in den griff
bekommen nun in dieser hinsicht müssen
lokale auch eine runde applaus geben el
salvador war eines der ersten länder das
gehandelt hat zum zeitpunkt der
erstellung dieses videos waren es aber
doch bereits 14 prozent der bevölkerung
geimpft eine spektakuläre zahlen
vergleichsmieten staaten und israel aber
bedenke dass wir hier über eines der
ersten länder lateinamerikas sprechen
all das erklärt warum die popularität
von mobile unschlagbar ist sagt der 88
prozent der salvadorianer sind mit
seiner regierung sehr zufrieden
und seine popularität ist nicht auf el
salvador beschränkt in der
internationalen politik hat ist pokale
geschafft das unmögliche zu erreichen
seine erste reise als präsident ging
nach washington dc dort traf er sich mit
transnationalen sicherheitsberater und
kritisierte offen china dies geschah im
märz 2009 10 und nur ein paar monate
später im dezember 2009 10 traf er sich
mit segal pink in china von dieser reise
sicherte er sich eine millionenschwere
investition china wird ein sportstadion
eine bibliothek eine
wasseraufbereitungsanlage und ein
urlaubs ressort bauen
mit anderen worten lokale bekommt
investitionen von überall aus den usa
japan und natürlich ist da noch der 389
millionen dollar kredit des
internationalen währungsfonds als corona
helfe mit anderen worten kehle sieht
ganz so aus wie man sich einen
politischen messias vorstellte ein
verlorenes land endlich herumreißt uns
und erfolg führt oder gar nicht was also
passt einigen nicht anleiten pele warum
sagen wir dass er eine so umstrittene
figur ist nun genau das verraten wir
euch jetzt also aufgepasst
melis dunkle seite
oberflächlich betrachtet sieht es so aus
als nur die kieler einen fantastischen
job im kampf gegen das verbrechen machen
aber wenn wir einen blick in die
vergangenheit werfen sehen wir dass dies
nicht das erste mal ist dass die
mordrate in el salvador gesunken ist
dürft mal einen blick auf diese kraft
hier kannst du klar erkennen wir auch im
jahr 2012 die zahl der tötungsdelikte
dramatisch gesunken ist der die games
hat nicht einen waffenstillstand
geschlossen sobald er waffenstillstand
auch bei war stieg die gewalt hier an
und wenn du genau hinsieht kannst du
sehen dass die mehrzahl im jahr 2015
ihren höhepunkt erreichten aber bereits
vor dem sieg pokals zu sinken begann mit
anderen worten können wir wirklich sagen
dass pokal ist eiserne faust die ursache
ist das aktuelle motiv ist nun zur zeit
ist es einfach noch zu früh um ein
endgültiges urteil zu fällen was jedoch
mit sicherheit sagen können ist dass bog
er ist vater hand gehen mehr als
wahlkampfgetöse ist sehr viel mehr
vokale ermächtigt polizei nach blutigen
wochenende banken mitglieder in el
salvador zu töten aber warte ein moment
denn das ist noch nicht alles eine
weitere von mobile strategien und die
gewalt zu beenden sind verhandlungen im
september 2012 veröffentlicht die
zeitung als pharo diesen investigativen
artikel lokale verhandelt mit ms 13
einer salvadorianischen gang über die
reduzierung der morde und unterstützung
bei den wahlen erfahrung diese zeitung
hat geliebte dokumente vorgelegt die
details dieser verhandlungen zeigen die
game hat privilegiert an mitglieder im
gefängnis ausgehandelten austausch für
eine reduzierung der morde und die
unterstützung bei kiel ist bei den
anstehenden wahlen und wie du dir
vorstellen kannst steht dies in krassem
widerspruch zur burg elis heiligem
wahlkampfversprechen dass er niemals mit
kriminellen verhandeln würde und welche
konsequenzen hat er diese enthüllungen
der zeitung el faro reagierte pokale
zunächst einmal hat seine regierung
gegen die journalistin ermittlungen
wegen möglicher geldwäsche eingeleitet
und das ist erst der anfang okay geht
auch öffentlich gegen
regierungskritische medien wie zb social
prize for aber ich weiß was viele von
euch jetzt denken das sind auch nur
nebensächlichkeiten lokale ist weder der
erste noch der letzte politiker der
medien angreiferin kritisieren er ist
halt ein wenig eitel 111 präsident eben
und du hast recht denn wirklich
besorgniserregend ist dass folgende
[Musik]
schwer bewaffnete polizei und soldaten
betreten das parlament von el salvador
wie sie ja was meinst du ist das wieder
ein staatsstreich in el salvador tropico
in real life nun nichts dergleichen es
war neid boucle höchstpersönlich der
dena de ist parlament geschickt hat und
warum es einfach die regierung wollte
dass das parlament einen kredit in höhe
von 109 millionen dollar absegnet um die
polizei zu modernisieren sie wollten
hubschrauber patrouillenwagen oder
überwachungs auslastung kaufen und so
beliebte kehle auch ist er hat nicht die
uneingeschränkte unterstützung des
parlaments gehabt vergesst nicht dass er
bis dahin nur eine präsidentschaftswahl
gewonnen hat aber das parlament wurde
immer noch von den beiden großen
traditionellen parteien dominiert
also schickte die armee um sie ein wenig
einzuschüchtern nur ein bisschen
motivation damit sie diesen
klitzekleinen kredit zustimmen mit dem
die von vogue elle kontrollierte polizei
hochgerüstet wird was kann daran denn
schon anrüchig seien nun all dies
geschah im februar 2020 einer später im
februar 2021 fanden in ascot
parlamentswahlen statt und wie du dir
vorstellen kannst wurden die
traditionellen parteien praktischen
weggefegt mit so viel unterstützung der
bevölkerung kehle nach der absoluten
macht gegriffen und die eine vorstellung
zu geben die legislative von eisschilden
84 abgeordnete 64 von ihnen sind nun
pokal ist verbündete nur 20 gehören der
opposition an nokia hat so wird die
totale kontrolle über exekutive und
legislative was fehlt also noch zur
absoluten herrschaft genau die
judikative el salvadors parlament
entlässt die obersten richter des landes
wir konnten ist ich weiß was die wir von
euch denken in einem so großen land el
salvador ist es normal dass lokale alle
richter die während der vorgänger
regierung ernannt wurden beseitigen will
und du hast recht aber es ist auch wahr
dass eine art politik zu machen immer
autoritärer wirkt im moment kontrolliert
bikila also die exekutive die
legislative und judikative ist das also
etwas wofür wir ihn verurteilen sollten
nun in mancherlei hinsicht vielleicht
nicht aber es ist ein hohes risiko denn
niemand kann bestreiten dass nokia in
seinem land extrem populär ist und dass
er wahlen gewonnen hat aber eine
derartige konzentration von macht ist
immer ein schlechtes omen und das
erklärt warum sich die usa davor hüten
einen möchtegern tyrannis elfi
schafspelz zu unterstützen
[Musik]
usa streichen geld dafür es war dort
wegen schwerwiegender bedenken über die
kürzliche entlassung aller hohen richter
rogers ist dies eine gute oder eine
schlechte entscheidung momentan ist die
schwer zu sagen auf der einen seite ist
es klar dass el salvador einen
drastischen wechsel in seiner politik
braucht es ist schwierig die korruption
in einem land zu beenden wenn alle alten
eliten gegen dich sind andererseits wäre
es nicht das erste mal dass ein
messianischer führer in lateinamerika
auftaucht der am ende zum tyrannen wird
und deswegen ist die frage nun an dich
gerichtet denkst du dass es gut ist dass
die vereinigten staaten oder die
europäische union druck auf gbagbo
ausüben um zu verhindern dass ein
diktator wird oder ist vielleicht für
eine weile eine gewisse härte nötig
damit das land der kriminalität und
korruption einzusetzen kann wird pokale
das schicksal des salvators langfristig
überhaupt ändern können oder geben ihnen
die banken nur eine verschnaufpause
alles ist nur ein strohfeuer oder in ein
paar jahren sehen wir wieder hohe
mordrate de und die teile deine meinung
bitte wie immer mit uns und allen
anderen im kommentarbereich unter diesem
video falls sie dieses video gefallen
hat geht uns bitte einen like teil der
iss mit deinen freunden und abonniere
unseren kanal vergisst auch nicht das
glück zu aktivieren damit ihr keines
unserer zukünftigen videos entgeht
macht's gut und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]